I have to tell you on a personal note
every day my kids asked me who's on the
show today and I tell them we got a lot
of cool people here no I was like all
right and today I told them that you
were here and they lost their minds
absolutely lost their minds and suddenly
for about eight seconds I had their
respect yeah
that's it's called that was that yeah it
was the Hamilton effect yeah yeah that's
like most of what I do these days is
take selfies with parents so they can
feel cool for their kids yeah yeah it's
a weird transference it doesn't make me
cool it gives me an aura of cool but
it's very quick it's like a flashbulb of
cool and then it wears off and they
realize oh it's just you again yeah
really it's really all any of us can
hope for you know it's so funny
Hamilton you it's been how long since
you left the cast like a year and a half
and how long did you do the show for the
original cast show almost three years
almost county years and that when did
you in that in the run did you realize
what a phenomenon it was how long did it
take for that to sink in not till I was
done what yeah I mean I because it was
the biggest thing in the world you must
have known that while you were doing it
no man when you're doing it it's like
it's like ah my knees hurt and like oh
man I don't want to get on the subway
and go to work and yet like it's it's a
job like everybody like do you hate your
job right yeah I mean yeah you know you
hate your job oh my god
yeah yeah you have days where no matter
how great your job is you have days
where you don't you're not trying to go
there yes yeah I had there are a lot of
those days when you do that show that
many times like number playing you're
playing two roles it's demanding and
you're thinking so when when it was over
when you were done that's when you got
to actually move around in the world and
realize oh this had a huge effect on
people's lives yeah yeah because I think
when when you're in it you're you're
building in you're working and you don't
get to experience everyone's reaction to
it but out outside in the world you get
to you know you start getting letters
from kids or you know popping up on
social media telling you how sort of
important how much confidence they have
gained since obsessing over the Hamilton
soundtrack for a long time really is I
feel incredibly lucky to have been a
part of a thing that turns out was so
important and continues to be so
impressed for so many people
you